You know, I don't want you to have your car get broken into or the tires stolen or, you know, the full self-driving hacked and it programmed to, you know, drive you into a lake or something. You know, so at one point they were the cool car. I remember a period of time where when you saw Tesla, like, ooh, that's a Tesla, how exotic and cool. And yeah, I mean, it is funny how the symbolism, the connotations associated with certain things can change very quickly. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 228 recorded on March 20th, 2025. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we chat about Tesla, Twitter and Elon. It's only going to be a 22 minute episode, folks.
你知道，我不希望你的车被砸、轮胎被偷，或者全自动驾驶系统被黑，被编程设定成把你开进湖里之类的。你知道，曾经有一段时间，特斯拉是酷车的代名词。我记得有一段时间，当你看到特斯拉时，会觉得“噢，那是特斯拉，多新奇、多酷啊”。确实，符号和内涵与某些事物关联的方式变化之快，真是令人玩味。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 228 期，录制于 2025 年 3 月 20 日。我是 Connor，今天我和联合主持人 Bryce 一起聊聊特斯拉、Twitter 和埃隆。各位，这期节目只有 22 分钟。
So part three of this recording, which I believe puts us on like episode 2...28 potentially. We have to revisit a topic we talked about and this is a, you know, we went from GTC to GTC Nvidia stuff to now this is a less technical topic folks, but every once in a while I like to get hot takes from Bryce and for the avid listener. You will recall, I think it aired in February, but the discussion was in January. I think it was literally one or two days after, we'll call it Elon's most notable snafu. And for those of you that don't know what I'm talking about, I don't know, get out from the rock that you're living under. And at that point, I said that my partner and I were thinking about buying a Tesla in the next year and I was
这是本期录音的第三部分，我想这应该是第 228 期节目了。我们必须重温一个之前讨论过的话题，我们从 GTC 聊到英伟达，现在这个话题没那么硬核了，但偶尔我也想听听 Bryce 的犀利观点。对于忠实听众来说，你们可能记得，这期节目应该是在二月播出的，但讨论是在一月进行的。我想那是在埃隆最著名的那次闹剧发生后的一两天。对于那些不知道我在说什么的人，我不知道该说什么，从你躲着的石头底下出来吧。当时我说，我和我的伴侣正考虑在未来一年内买一辆特斯拉，而我
having some moral qualms with is it okay to to buy a product from someone that is maybe doing some things you don't agree with and you. My moral compass at times, very you know not very often but at times, Bryce you gave me the go-ahead and said I don't need to feel bad. That was in January. It is now, as we've mentioned a couple times, March 20th. And I just, I think I tweeted it, I posted it, whatever all the words are, across both Blue Sky, Twitter, and Mastodon, the irony of posting it on Twitter, aka X, which is run by Elon. A 45-minute video of the, what some people are calling Tesla terrorism of you know cars wheels being uh you know there was like 60 cars that got their wheels stolen um you know vehicles that are being
当时有一些道德上的顾虑，比如从一个可能在做一些你不认同的事情的人那里购买产品是否妥当。我的道德准则有时，你知道，虽然不常发生，但有时会动摇。Bryce，你当时给了我许可，说我不必感到内疚。那是在一月。现在，正如我们提到的，已经是 3 月 20 日了。我刚刚，我想我发了推文，或者不管叫什么，在 Blue Sky、Twitter 和 Mastodon 上都发了。讽刺的是，我是在由埃隆掌管的 Twitter（也就是 X）上发布了那段 45 分钟的视频，视频里是有些人所说的“特斯拉恐怖主义”，你知道，有 60 辆车的轮子被偷了，还有车辆在
lit on fire I think in some states shots were fired at Tesla dealerships none of which obviously we condone um but the the I would like to revisit I thought it was Incredible like how quickly the timing was that we happened to be recording like a couple days after that happened and at the time I would say that things were what's the word less heated or maybe less controversial It was still controversial what was going on, but now we are three months or I guess two months later and also on top of that the Tesla stock price has absolutely plummeted. It seems like the kind of the inverse of GameStop from however many years ago that was. Redditors and folks that are not a fan of Elon are taking to
一些州被纵火，我想在某些地方还有人向特斯拉经销商开枪。当然，我们绝不赞同这些行为。但我还是想重温一下，我觉得很不可思议，我们录音的时间点刚好在那件事发生几天后。当时我会说，情况怎么说呢，没那么激烈，或者说没那么有争议。虽然当时发生的事情本身就有争议，但现在三个月，或者说两个月过去了，而且最重要的是，特斯拉的股价已经彻底暴跌了。这看起来就像是几年前 GameStop 事件的翻版。Reddit 用户和那些不喜欢埃隆的人开始
shorting Tesla or selling the shares that they may or may not have owned. Anyways, and I just, I was just, well actually I won't say who I was visiting and conversing with, but they were concerned when I said that I was, you know, still interested in buying a Tesla, but even more concerned now about the morality of it. And this individual was like, really? Like, you would still still buy a Tesla what they're calling a swastika I I was like you know I'm still all about that FSD full self driving 13.0 I don't want to support this person but I do want to not have to drive my vehicle and I don't have access to BYD which is only sold in China slash Europe. I heard yesterday in the keynote that Nvidia is partnering with GM for their self-autonomous vehicles. Happy to buy one of those when they come out.
做空特斯拉，或者抛售他们可能持有也可能没持有的股票。总之，我当时，其实我不会说我在拜访谁、和谁交谈，但当我提到我仍然有兴趣买特斯拉时，他们很担心，而且现在对这种行为的道德性更加担忧了。那个人说：“真的吗？你还会买特斯拉？他们管那叫纳粹标志。”我说，你知道，我还是非常看好 FSD 全自动驾驶 13.0。我不想支持这个人，但我确实不想自己开车，而且我用不上比亚迪，那只在中国和欧洲销售。我昨天在主题演讲中听说英伟达正在与通用汽车合作开发自动驾驶汽车。等那些车出来，我很乐意买一辆。
Anyways, that's my monologue out of the way. So my question to you is what are your updated thoughts and feelings if you've been paying attention to both Tesla, Elon, and as one of the previous episodes was titled, the slow death of Twitter, as I have started to see the graphics and images and past tweets, they're kind of just disappearing. You can't find them now. Anyways, I'm done talking.
总之，我的独白就到这里。所以我的问题是，如果你一直关注特斯拉、埃隆，以及正如之前某一期节目的标题所说，“Twitter 的缓慢死亡”，你现在的想法和感受是什么？因为我已经开始看到那些图形、图像和过去的推文正在消失。你现在已经找不到了。总之，我说完了。
Yeah, I was, I could not find my 2017 GTC keynote Twitter thread. I tried really hard and then I asked a couple of different large language models with search capabilities to try hard and to no avail. Maybe it has disappeared from the Internet. I had an interesting conversation at dinner last night with some of my colleagues where we were discussing the presence of an American flag on outside of someone's house. Also pause, because this is going to be a bit political. We should very clearly state these are our personal views.
是的，我当时找不到我 2017 年 GTC 主题演讲的 Twitter 帖子了。我非常努力地寻找，然后我问了几个带有搜索功能的大型语言模型，试图努力寻找，但无济于事。也许它已经从互联网上消失了。昨晚在晚餐时，我和同事进行了一次有趣的谈话，我们讨论了某人房子外面悬挂美国国旗的问题。先暂停一下，因为这会涉及一点政治。我们应该非常明确地声明，这些是我们的个人观点。
These do not represent the views of our employer whatsoever. Everything said here on out is just Bryce and myself talking. But yes, American flag. So we were talking about the display of an American flag outside of a house and about why we were talking about like why is it that some people or that in some parts of the US it is seen that just putting the flag outside of your house sends a message about your political ideology. And I don't, you know, for a variety of reasons,
这些绝不代表我们雇主的观点。从现在开始所说的一切都只是我和 Bryce 的闲聊。但确实，美国国旗。我们当时在讨论在房子外面展示美国国旗，以及为什么我们讨论说，为什么在美国的某些地方，仅仅在房子外面挂上国旗就会传递出关于你政治意识形态的信息。我不想，你知道，出于各种原因，
I'm not going to get into my thoughts on that or like how that discussion went, but I think that the reality is that, and this reminds me of when I was working on the inclusive terminology standard. And when we did that work, we came up with this notion that terms have both their connotation and what they're intended to mean, and then they have their intended meaning and then they have their connotations, right? Their maybe unintended and secondary meanings. And like putting a flag in front of your house, That that is not intended like that the primary meaning of a flag is not to To send this like a message about your politics within the US right? It's the primary
我不会深入探讨我的想法或那次讨论的经过，但我认为事实是，这让我想起了我参与制定包容性术语标准的时候。当我们做那项工作时，我们提出了一个概念，即术语既有其内涵，也有其预期含义，然后它们有预期含义，接着还有它们的联想意义，对吧？也许是无意的和次要的含义。就像在房子前面挂一面旗帜，那并不是故意的，旗帜的主要含义并不是为了在美国境内传递关于你政治立场的信息，对吧？它的主要
intention of the flag is to be a representation of the country, but then it's taken on this connotative meaning and I think that the Tesla brand has started to take on these connotations. It's starting to become a political statement, right? Especially like with the Cybertruck. Like I think I don't want to put people into categories, but I suspect that a lot of people who have bought
意图是作为国家的代表，但它后来带上了这种联想意义。我认为特斯拉品牌已经开始带上这些联想了。它开始变成一种政治声明，对吧？尤其是像 Cybertruck。我想，我不想把人分类，但我怀疑很多买了
a Cybertruck have a certain political leaning. And certainly, even if you don't have that political idea, on to categories, but I suspect that a lot of people who have bought a cyber truck have a certain political leaning. And certainly, even if you don't have that political ideology, you must know if you're buying a cyber truck that people will think that that means that you are a supporter of Elon and that you are maybe a supporter of the current administration. And you know, obviously, I think it's very sad because I have friends who work at Tesla, I have friends that work at SpaceX, and they make amazing products. And it's sad that it has become politicized and I feel for them and I feel for people who like I have we both
Cybertruck 的人都有一定的政治倾向。当然，即使你没有那种政治意识形态，你也一定知道，如果你买了 Cybertruck，人们会认为这意味着你是埃隆的支持者，也许还是现任政府的支持者。你知道，显然，我觉得这很可悲，因为我有朋友在特斯拉工作，我有朋友在 SpaceX 工作，他们制造了很棒的产品。令人难过的是，它变得政治化了，我为他们感到难过，也为那些像我们一样的人感到难过。我们都有
have friends who who own Teslas and did not mean to make a political statement but I do think that it's it's reached a point where yeah maybe maybe one like it's it's awful if you have to think about whether owning a particular car, what owning a particular car says about you. I understand your perspective, Kano, that you just want the technology, right? But I do think we're in a place now where it does send a particular message. And maybe that's always been the case because I remember back when SUVs became popular in the early 2000s, you know, and then the Prius came out, you know, the Prius was a car that
朋友拥有特斯拉，本意并非要发表政治声明，但我确实认为它已经到了一个地步，是的，也许，如果你必须考虑拥有一辆特定的车意味着什么，那真的很糟糕。我理解你的观点，Connor，你只是想要这项技术，对吧？但我确实认为我们现在所处的环境，它确实传递了某种特定的信息。也许情况一直如此，因为我记得 2000 年代初 SUV 流行的时候，你知道，后来普锐斯出来了，你知道，普锐斯就是一辆
clearly sent maybe not a political message but some sort of message about your values, right? Yeah, I mean, what's interesting is when you initially said owning a Cybertruck probably indicates which way you lean. My first thought was like, wait a sec, when did the Cybertruck come out? Because at one point, like owning a Tesla, like Elon used to identify or I don't know what, you know, at some points he said he was politically neutral but it used to be this like kind of you know good for the planet climate change is happening kind of tech forward I identified it more with like you know more like democratic values
清楚地传递了，也许不是政治信息，但某种关于你价值观的信息的车，对吧？是的，有趣的是，当你最初说拥有 Cybertruck 可能表明你的倾向时，我的第一反应是：等一下，Cybertruck 是什么时候出来的？因为曾经有一段时间，拥有特斯拉，埃隆过去常标榜，或者我不知道，你知道，在某些时候他说他是政治中立的，但它过去更像是那种，你知道，对地球有益、气候变化正在发生、技术领先的形象，我更多地将其与，你知道，更像民主党的价值观
in the states or whatever and only until recently in the last whatever I don't even know how many months or years it was has he has he swapped and that's why Like there's a bunch. I'm not sure if you've heard about this You probably didn't watch that video that I posted but people have started putting stickers on their Tesla's because you know of the damage The tires being stolen keys being happened, you know, some people are spray painting swastikas on on Tesla's They started putting these stickers on the bumper stickers that say, you know, I bought this before Elon went crazy. And to try and like let people know that like I didn't buy this to support Elon, I bought it because I like the car. I wanted an EV. And anyways, the point being is when you actually first said that I was like, actually, does he mean left or does he mean
在美国之类的联系在一起。直到最近，在过去的几个月或几年里，他才发生了转变。这就是为什么，有一大堆。我不确定你是否听说过这个，你可能没看我发的那个视频，但人们已经开始在他们的特斯拉上贴贴纸了，因为你知道，车辆受损、轮胎被偷、钥匙被划，你知道，有些人甚至在特斯拉上喷涂纳粹标志。他们开始在保险杠上贴这些贴纸，上面写着：“我在埃隆变疯之前买的。”试图让人们知道，我买这个不是为了支持埃隆，我买它是为了车本身。我想要一辆电动车。总之，重点是，当你第一次说那话时，我当时想，其实，他是指左派还是指
right? And like, I think, you know, Cybertruck is the most Elon-esque of the vehicles. I personally would never buy it because I think it's ugly as hell. Yeah, it's interesting that like there's a history of that. Like at one point, Tesla's were kind of like the status symbol in Silicon Valley, you know, like. At one point, they were the cool car. I remember a period of time where when you saw a Tesla, like, oh, that's a Tesla. How exotic and cool. And, yeah, I mean, it is funny how the symbolism, the connotations associated with certain things
右派？而且，我认为，你知道，Cybertruck 是最具有“埃隆风格”的车型。我个人永远不会买它，因为我觉得它丑死了。是的，有趣的是，这背后有一段历史。曾经有一段时间，特斯拉在硅谷就像是一种身份象征，你知道。曾经有一段时间，它们是酷车。我记得有一段时间，当你看到特斯拉时，会觉得“噢，那是特斯拉，多新奇、多酷啊”。而且，确实，符号和内涵与某些事物关联的方式变化之快，真是令人玩味。
can change very quickly. And also to be clear, when I was talking to that individual who I don't wanna identify, that they were concerned that I was interested in getting a Tesla, it got lost on them for like the first hour of the conversation that like, how come I just don't look at other EVs, et cetera? I've looked, I've watched so many MKBHD, I believe is his five acronym, uh,
另外要说明的是，当我和那个我不愿透露姓名的人交谈时，他们担心我有兴趣买特斯拉，在谈话的前一个小时里，他们完全没听进去我说的“为什么我不看看其他电动车”之类的。我看过，我看过很多 MKBHD，我相信是他的五个首字母缩写，呃，
the tech reviewer on YouTube. Uh, uh, he has a whole autofocus, um, MKBHD YouTube channel. I've watched all the EV videos and, uh, some of them look great. None of them have the two places for your cell phones but the main thing is none of them come remotely close to the self-driving. That is what I am after and I have heard BYD is phenomenally good in China but you can't get a BYD car anywhere in North America, at least that I know of. So it's like I'm open to buying a different EV but it's like there's no competitor in the FSD space Anyways in case in case that's not clear. But yes, you were about to say something. Yeah
YouTube 上的科技评论员。呃，他有一个完整的 Autofocus，呃，MKBHD YouTube 频道。我看过所有关于电动车的视频，呃，有些看起来很棒。没有一辆车能像特斯拉那样为你的手机提供两个放置位，但最主要的是，没有一辆车在自动驾驶方面能与之相提并论。这就是我想要的。我听说比亚迪在中国表现得非常好，但在北美任何地方都买不到比亚迪，至少我所知是这样。所以我对购买其他电动车持开放态度，但问题是 FSD 领域没有竞争对手。总之，以防万一还没说清楚。但是的，你刚才想说什么。是的，
well, I mean and I think it'll be interesting to see I think we're gonna see a lot of a lot more Self-driving developments the next couple years. I mean, I know everybody's been saying that for a while, but I do think that we're going to start to see other players catch up. It does seem like the AV industry Twitter and the slow death of Twitter. And you and I have talked about reasons we haven't left the platform yet. You mentioned in the past that one of the reasons
嗯，我的意思是，我认为看看未来几年自动驾驶的发展会很有趣。我知道大家已经这么说很久了，但我确实认为我们将开始看到其他参与者迎头赶上。自动驾驶行业、Twitter 以及 Twitter 的缓慢死亡，这看起来确实如此。你和我讨论过我们还没离开这个平台的原因。你过去提到过，其中一个原因
you didn't leave is you still feel like you were getting better engagement on Twitter than on other platforms. And I've noticed, ever since Elon Elon took over that I've gotten less engagement, still more than on other platforms but less engagement. But I have up until I've tweeted a bit at GTC and some of those things have gotten good engagement but for me, one of the reasons I've been more active on Twitter recently is I sort of wanted to test whether it's still a good platform, whether it's still a platform that I get engagement on and in particular I've been posting things on both LinkedIn and Twitter to see
你没离开是因为你觉得在 Twitter 上获得的互动仍然比其他平台好。我注意到，自从埃隆接管以来，我的互动量减少了，虽然仍然比其他平台多，但互动量确实减少了。但我一直，我在 GTC 上发了一些推文，其中一些获得了不错的互动。但对我来说，我最近在 Twitter 上更活跃的原因之一是，我想测试一下它是否仍然是一个好的平台，是否仍然是一个我能获得互动的平台。特别是，我一直在 LinkedIn 和 Twitter 上发布内容，看看
sort of comparatively at how much engagement I get on those two platforms because I think if I was going to exit Twitter probably LinkedIn would be the place that I would that I would be because I'm primarily on Twitter to reach my my professional network to reach you know other programmers to spread the word about things that that you know that I'm doing at work or that that I am passionate about in the in space. And I feel like LinkedIn is the most established platform alternative for me to do that. And I do still think it's true that I'm getting more engagement on Twitter than on other platforms. However, I think based on what the amount of engagement that I am getting on LinkedIn,
相对而言，我在这两个平台上获得的互动量有多少。因为我觉得如果我要退出 Twitter，LinkedIn 可能是我的去处，因为我主要在 Twitter 上接触我的专业网络，接触其他程序员，传播我在工作中正在做的事情，或者我在领域内热衷的事情。我觉得 LinkedIn 是我这样做最成熟的替代平台。我仍然认为我在 Twitter 上获得的互动确实比其他平台多。然而，我认为基于我在 LinkedIn 上获得的互动量，
I think if I committed myself to more regularly posting on LinkedIn and building up my following on LinkedIn, I would probably get equal to or more engagement there. And I know that there's some number of people that I can no longer reach on Twitter because people have left for another platform. So I think at the very least it's likely that I will be posting across both Twitter and LinkedIn for my various social media stuff going forward. I maybe will take another look at Blue Sky again but it's like it would be hard for me to commit to doing three. It's even hard for me to keep up with just doing two or even just the one.
我觉得如果我致力于更定期地在 LinkedIn 上发帖并建立我的粉丝群，我可能会在那里获得相等或更多的互动。而且我知道有些人在 Twitter 上已经无法触及了，因为人们已经转投其他平台了。所以我认为至少，未来我可能会在 Twitter 和 LinkedIn 上同时发布我的各种社交媒体内容。我可能会再看看 Blue Sky，但要我同时经营三个平台很难。甚至要跟上两个，或者仅仅一个，对我来说都很吃力。
Yeah, I mean, as long as you're tweeting from your computer, I don't actually find it too much hassle. Like that's been my kind of my, I have mentioned it earlier that my goals is I post to all three. Although admittedly I posted to Twitter, the Jensen versus Bryce one, I did it to Blue Sky. And then when I was copying and pasting the images to Mastodon, I just got two, five, oh three hours. 503 errors and I was like, alright mastodon is not getting this one and
是的，我的意思是，只要你是从电脑上发推文，我其实觉得没那么麻烦。这就是我的一种，我之前提到过，我的目标是我在三个平台上都发。虽然不得不承认，我发到 Twitter 上的那个 Jensen 对阵 Bryce 的帖子，我也发到了 Blue Sky。然后当我把图片复制粘贴到 Mastodon 时，我连续收到了两三次 503 错误，我就想，好吧，Mastodon 这次发不出去了，而且
Or it like I didn't even give me an error I just saw on the bottom left corner of the screen a little a little like translucent 503 thing and I was like, okay Well, I'm in the middle of recording a podcast. I'm not I'm not gonna figure this out. But yeah, I mean it's it's clear to me I think that like Elon is slowly destroying a lot of the, I don't even want to say companies that he's created, companies that he has acquired slash grown, because I'm not sure. I mean, Tesla, he stole or bought and then sued into oblivion, the people he bought it from. Twitter, he accidentally tweeted and then ended up having to buy.
或者它甚至没给我报错，我只是在屏幕左下角看到了一个半透明的 503 提示，我就想，好吧，我正在录播客，我没空去研究这个。但确实，在我看来，埃隆正在慢慢摧毁他所创造的，或者说他收购并壮大的很多公司，因为我不确定。我的意思是，特斯拉，他窃取或收购了它，然后起诉了原创始人直到他们破产。Twitter，他意外发了推文，结果不得不买下它。
And that whole saga was nuts. Yeah, and now he's, I don't know what the verb is for what he's doing to your governmental infrastructures. But you know, the question is, you know, what, how should I feel? You know, this is going to be the ongoing quarterly Tesla update with Bryce, with Bryce as my moral compass. He said it was OK in January 2025. You might be listening to this in April, but recording this March 20th. What does Bryce say now? I guess, I guess I, I still think it's OK for you to get a Tesla if you want to get a Tesla however, I would I would not advise doing so because
整个过程简直疯了。是的，现在他正在，我不知道他对他所接手的政府基础设施在做什么。但你知道，问题是，你知道，我该有什么感觉？你知道，这将是 Bryce 作为我的道德指南针，与我进行的持续性季度特斯拉更新。他在 2025 年 1 月说没问题。你可能在四月听到这期节目，但我们是在 3 月 20 日录制的。Bryce 现在怎么说？我想，我想我仍然认为如果你想买特斯拉，买一辆是可以的，不过，我不会建议这样做，因为
Like I know that let me put it in a way I I think I know that you buying a Tesla wouldn't buy it as it means to support Elon and Not not not as an indication of some political view. But some people would read it that way. And I don't want you to have your car get broken into or the tires stolen or the full self-driving hacked and it programmed to drive you into a lake or something. programmed to, you know, drive you into a lake or something.
就像我知道，让我换个说法，我知道你买特斯拉并不是为了支持埃隆，也不是为了表达某种政治观点。但有些人会那样解读。我不希望你的车被砸、轮胎被偷，或者全自动驾驶系统被黑，被编程设定成把你开进湖里之类的。
You know, so. So I think maybe now is not the time. Now is not the time. That is interesting. I've never I've never thought because that's the thing is on one hand, you're looking at like the second hand market value of Tesla's is plummeting right now. So from a former actuaries, someone who has studied arbitrage and statistics, see a lot of value here, is arbitrage.
你知道，所以。所以我认为也许现在不是时候。现在不是时候。这很有趣。我从来没想过，因为问题在于，一方面，你看到特斯拉的二手市场价值正在暴跌。所以作为一个前精算师，一个研究过套利和统计学的人，我在这里看到了很多价值，这就是套利。
What used to be market value has crashed even though the actual like tangible value of these things has not changed, but I guess it's because of the risk that something's gonna happen. So part of my thought is like, maybe I'll just buy a secondhand Tesla at bottom for pennies on the dollar.
曾经的市场价值已经崩盘，尽管这些东西的实际有形价值并没有改变，但我猜这是因为人们担心会发生什么事。所以我的一部分想法是，也许我会以极低的价格买一辆二手特斯拉。
And then just put a sticker on just put a sticker on it saying I bought this after, you know, after Elon went crazy. However, I'm an actuary and I just saw a good value opportunity. I was thinking that like in the thousands of dollars I would save buying a secondhand one plus while its market value is plummeting, I could spend like a grand of that on a custom paint job that's like, you know, full blown Canadian maple leaf flag and that's got some big signs that says, you know, Elon sucks or something. More is like, that I just want to go around saying that although I will I don't think I'm ever on record saying this because we try to
然后贴个贴纸，写上“我在埃隆变疯之后买的”。然而，我是一名精算师，我刚刚看到了一个很好的价值机会。我在想，买二手车能省下几千美元，而且当它的市场价值暴跌时，我可以花一千块钱做一个定制喷漆，比如，全幅的加拿大枫叶旗，上面写着大大的“埃隆是个混蛋”之类的。更多的是，我只是想四处宣扬这一点，尽管我不认为我曾经公开说过这些，因为我们尽量
Not say politically neutral, but focus more on tech topics. I have despised Elon ever since I read Ashley Vance's Biography on him where there's this there's a I don't I don't think I think it's I think that you can dislike Elon without it being political. Uh, I think so But I also think that there's like a large number of folks that if you say something bad about someone, you know That they admire for whatever reason now, they're gonna hold it against you Which I guess you know as the older we get we should be less concerned with Upsetting folks, you know, if you've been listening this long for 220 however episodes
不说政治中立，而是专注于科技话题。自从我读了阿什利·万斯写的埃隆传记后，我就一直鄙视他。我不认为，我认为你可以不喜欢埃隆而不涉及政治。我想是的，但我同时也认为，有很多人，如果你说了他们出于某种原因崇拜的人的坏话，他们就会记恨你。我想，随着年龄增长，我们应该少关心惹恼别人，你知道，如果你已经听了这么久，听了 220 多期节目，
You can tolerate an opinion. You't agree with. It's fine. But yeah, there's a chapter in the book which covers him firing his secretary of 20 years when she asks for a raise and Elon says, how about you take a two week vacation and I'll let you know how I feel and then the idea being like oh, how much do I need this person and apparently like After she was just anyway, she gets back from the two weeks. He says you're free to go I don't need you anymore and there was a couple of executives that left because they were so appalled that like the only reason that they were willing to work with Elon because was because the secretary was so good at like monitoring his emotional state and basically like had like a
你应该能容忍与你不同的观点。没关系。但书中有一章提到他解雇了为他工作 20 年的秘书，当时她要求加薪，埃隆说：“不如你休两周假，我再告诉你我的感受。”然后他的想法是，哦，我有多需要这个人？显然，在她休完两周假回来后，他说：“你可以走了，我不再需要你了。”有几位高管因此辞职，因为他们感到非常震惊，他们愿意与埃隆共事的唯一原因，就是那位秘书非常擅长监控他的情绪状态，基本上就像有一个
Not physical but like they would check in with this the executive secretary is now a good time And then she'd be like now you come back tomorrow when Wednesday's not looking like a good day And that was the only reason that these folks would work with him Who knows how much of that is true? but I I imagine that the firing of the person is an actual true story and For someone that's worked for you for two decades. I just thought I just like What kind of what kind of person does that you know? What kind of person not a nice person and ever since I've never been a good big fan and now he's doing all this stuff
不是物理上的，但他们会和执行秘书确认：“现在是好时机吗？”然后她会说：“现在不行，你明天再来，周三看起来不是个好日子。”而这就是这些人愿意与他共事的唯一原因。谁知道其中有多少是真的？但我认为解雇那个人的事是一个真实的故事。对于一个为你工作了二十年的人，我只是觉得，这是什么样的人啊？什么样的人会这样做？不是个好人。从那以后，我就没怎么喜欢过他，而现在他还在做所有这些事情。
as of late and Yeah, anyway, so Bryce is at the Q2 mark. He says, feel free to buy, but at your own peril. Maybe not a good idea. What do you, what maybe, maybe can I get some, do you have any predictions? Where, where is this going? Is, is, is he going to be ousted as CEO of one of his companies soon? Where is this going? Is he going to be ousted as CEO of one of his companies soon? I imagine the shareholders and the board of Tesla right now are going like, you know, it is not having our company associated with this guy.
最近，是的，总之，Bryce 在第二季度给出的建议是：可以买，但后果自负。也许不是个好主意。你有什么预测吗？这会走向何方？他很快会被踢出他旗下公司的 CEO 职位吗？这会走向何方？他很快会被踢出他旗下公司的 CEO 职位吗？我想特斯拉的股东和董事会现在一定在想，你知道，让我们的公司与这家伙联系在一起，
It's not doing us any favors right now, no? Yeah, I just don't understand it because, you know, the CEO of my company works very hard, like all the time. Nobody works harder at Nvidia, I think, the CEO of my company works very hard, like all the time. Nobody works harder at Nvidia, I think, than Jensen. And that inspires, you know, I think a great loyalty among employees. And I just don't understand how you can be a CEO of, like, multiple big tech companies effectively while you're also like doing the government thing I just I just I don't get it um you know
现在对我们没有任何好处，不是吗？是的，我只是不明白，因为，你知道，我们公司的 CEO 工作非常努力，一直都是。我觉得英伟达没有人比黄仁勋工作更努力，这激发了员工极大的忠诚度。我只是不明白，你怎么能同时有效地担任多家大型科技公司的 CEO，同时还在搞政府那一套？我就是，我就是不明白。嗯，你知道，
it it doesn't it doesn't seem sustainable to me what does that mean what does that mean though what do you think's gonna happen I don't know I don't know I mean maybe there's an argument that that it's better for the company is for him to be distracted with other stuff. Oh, it's better for the cup. Well, I mean, not when the distractions are leading to a cratering stock price. Yeah. I don't I don't think that he's going to be asked it. Really? I think he won't be ousted yet. Well, based on what we know right now, I don't think so. I mean, I think the whole tech sector has been in a bit of a pullback and I think investors will be a little bit patient.
这对我来说似乎不可持续。那是什么意思？那是什么意思呢？你觉得会发生什么？我不知道，我不知道。我的意思是，也许有人会争辩说，他分心于其他事情对公司更好。哦，对公司更好。嗯，我的意思是，当这些分心导致股价暴跌时，可不是这样。是的。我不认为他会被踢出局。真的吗？我觉得他还没到被踢出局的时候。嗯，基于我们目前所知，我不这么认为。我的意思是，我认为整个科技行业都在回调，我认为投资者会保持一点耐心。
Well time will tell folks. Check back in in three months for an updated conversation with Bryce and Connor on To Tesla or not to Tesla? Yeah, and we I mean so many other things we got to talk about there's we had a whole list of topics I'm not over that we didn't get to Yeah, you got it. You got it. You got it. We got to find a way for you to come next year It's really it's a shame that you've been at Nvidia for so long. You've never made it out to a GTC I mean admittedly for the first what was it?
好吧，时间会证明一切。三个月后再回来听 Bryce 和 Connor 的更新对话：买还是不买特斯拉？是的，我们还有太多其他事情要聊，我们有一长串话题还没聊到。是的，你说的对。你说的对。我们得想办法让你明年过来。你在英伟达待了这么久，从来没参加过 GTC，真是太遗憾了。我的意思是，不得不承认，前几年，那是多久？
I've been here for now five and a half years for the first like three and a half It wasn't possible that there were no GTC. I know it was yeah Yeah, yeah, and then just yeah in the last two years. I am gonna be on site in May for a research on site so Okay, nice nice Anyways, we got to let you go. What are any last things you want to share? With the at the end of this Tesla Twitter Elon episode Well, I mean I'll say that you know that we haven't even talked about the main reason that you shouldn't buy a Tesla
我在这里已经五年半了，前三年半是不可能的，因为那时没有 GTC。我知道，是的，是的，然后就在过去两年。我五月份会去现场进行研究，所以，好的，不错。总之，我们得让你走了。你还有什么想分享的吗？在这期特斯拉、Twitter 和埃隆的节目结束时。嗯，我的意思是，我会说，你知道，我们甚至还没谈到你不应该买特斯拉的主要原因。
Why is that doesn't have an Nvidia chip in it doesn't have an Nvidia? Like I said when I saw that GM announcement. I was like in my head I was like I hope this has been in the works and only just announced for two years and they actually have a car to release because like I like I said I am happy to buy the other self-autonomous driving car if it's good. We have partnerships, NVIDIA has partnerships with a ton of the self-driving car companies. But you know, I'm going to wait until we can buy the self-driving car in the employee gear store.
为什么？因为它没有英伟达芯片，没有英伟达？就像我说的，当我看到通用汽车的那个公告时，我心里想，我希望这已经在筹备中，只是刚刚宣布了两年，他们确实有车可以发布。因为就像我说的，如果好用，我很乐意买另一辆自动驾驶汽车。我们有合作伙伴关系，英伟达与许多自动驾驶汽车公司都有合作。但你知道，我会等到我们能在员工装备商店买到自动驾驶汽车的时候。
We've got to get that employee discount. They give us like the 25 bucks per quarter. Yeah, they give us the 25 bucks per quarter. Yeah, they give us the 25 bucks a quarter So somebody do the math on how many years you'd have to work at Nvidia to be able to get a free Free car 100 bucks a year. So I don't know Millennium or something like that. Probably that's not even enough Depending on how yeah costly the car is There is actually it's very cool. So they have a couple they have like the they have some cars here to test drive, like you can test drive a Lucid or a Pole Star. I actually have rented a car today and initially I messed it up so I had to like modify the reservation, but initially it was for a Pole Star, but...
我们得拿到那个员工折扣。他们每季度给我们 25 块钱。是的，他们每季度给我们 25 块钱。是的，他们每季度给我们 25 块钱。所以有人算算，在英伟达工作多少年才能买得起一辆免费的车？一年 100 块。所以我不知道，一千年之类的。可能那都不够，取决于车有多贵。其实这很酷。他们有几辆车在这里供试驾，比如你可以试驾 Lucid 或 Polestar。我今天其实租了一辆车，起初我弄错了，所以我不得不修改预订，但最初是一辆 Polestar，但是……
I had one in St. Louis, it was pretty cool. Is it good? Yeah I think so yeah. Alright well next time I rent a car I will attempt to get the Polestar that I missed out on. Alright we will let you go you got to get to GTC I assume. Yep I do. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening, we hope you enjoyed, and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我在圣路易斯开过一辆，挺酷的。好开吗？是的，我想是的。好吧，下次我租车时，我会尝试租那辆我错过的 Polestar。好吧，我们让你走，我猜你得去 GTC 了。是的，我得去了。请务必在你的播客应用或 ADSPthepodcast.com 上查看这些节目说明，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。